>> MARK REDI REPTING FROM
PALMEACH.
THANYO
JOING US NOW INEW
MPSHIRE'VERN
GORNOR, WELCTO FOX NEW
SUAY.
>> MORNIBROTR.
SIR, WANT TSTART WITHHE
C EXTERN REVW OUTHIS
EKFINDG DECIENES I
THR COVID-19 RESNSE.
TH AITTED EY HAVE ATIMES
T T COUSING GUIDANCE,
Y E AST.
NOTHEY'RE PLNINGN OVERHAUL
TOECOMA MO RAPID RESPO
PUIC HLTH AGCY.
YOU' BEEN GOVEOR
NAVITING THIPANDEMIC.
IS TT ENOU FOR YOU?
DO Y THI WITH THHEY CAN
FUNDED EERNAL REVIEWO XPAYER
OV THE PLACE?THEDC IS AL
FOTHLAST TWOEARS THEY SAY
ONE THG,HEY DO ATHER.
THEY TELL USNE TNG
THESE YSAVE ENONSTTL.
CKTRACKING.
SO I GSS THE ONLY GOODAKE
AWAYERE IS THERE
I INK EY'RE ARTI TO
ALIZE TH WE ARE REALLY O
OFHIS PANDIC.
'RE VINGORWARD AS A
COTRY.
LOL COROL AND LOL
PARENTS FAMILIESADE BY
E WE GOING TO HA CID
RGES COMG?
WE HAVE THE TOOLS.
HAVE E VACCINE,
THEREUTICS.
HAVE ALL ESTOOLIN O
I GUS IT'S GREAT TY'RE
FINALLY ACKNOWDGING
BU'SOMETNG THEEST OF
ERICHAS KNOWDGED FORHE
>> T REASOI TA ABOUT
BLIC TST.
CDC RECTAID, LISTEN,HEN
SAID TO FOLLOTHE SCIEE,
WEEVER SAID E SCNCE WAS
AND MY RESPONSWOULYOU
KIND OF DISAY E SCIENCE WAS
COLY WE ALL LISTED AS, AT
AST FROMHE LT, WERE ALL
LISTEDS BLIC HLTH THRES.
LOO WHEN OFFIALS COME O
TALKBOUTCIENCE, THERE'S ANND
IMPLIED UNDETANDG, T GUY
O WENT TMIAND STUDIED
SCIENCE AND ENGIERIN WHEN
DATA. SCNCE,OU'RE SAYING
YOU' SAYG WENOW WH'S
PPENG.
UNDSTAND IT
HERE'SHE RPONSE WE ND.
U CANNOT CE BACK OUTND S
SOTHING TOLLY FFERENT DO
THAD
MOMPORNTLY, WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE THE C, PEOE HA NO
TRUSIN T C.
WE D'TANT THAT, BUT
ARE TOY.Y THAT WHE WE
WI THEHITE HOU.RECR, HOSE
WOHAPPEN. TOLLY DIEREN
WE HAD TO BULE DOWN D KE
OUDECISIS.
WE KIND  LISNED TO WHAT EY
SAID
AY, HEAR YOU, BUT THISS
WHATE ARE EINGN
GRND.
I THK OVERALL GOVERNORS DID A
I N'SPEAFOR SOME OF OSE
BLUE STAS WITH ALL T
BEUSE,GAINTHEY KEPT DOING
WHATER T WHITE HOUSE AHE
CDWATELLTHEM ONE W
ANTHENHIFTING THNEXT WEEK,
ERODINTRUST TH WSHOU
A REAY SPONBILI
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
EARLIER.ABOUT ILDREN
COVID GUIDELINES F SCHOOLS,
JUSTS DS HEAD BA TO THE
CLASSROOMS.
THEYO LONGER RECMEND ROUNE
STINFOR GRADES K2 UNLESS
MMUNY TRANSMISSIONS HI.
DO Y SUPPO THACHANGE,
VERNOR
YH.
OKLOCALS AND SCHOOLS A
DECISIONFOR THEMLVES.
LIVE IN NEW MPSHE.
WE BIEVE IN SCOLS KING
NOT VING THE FERAL OR EV
THSTATGOVERNME COME WN
AND PUSH CERTAIN ANSWERSN TO
THEMND CERTAINROTOLS ON
THEM.
PECIALLYHEREE ARE NO
KNOWING WEAVE L THTOOL
INHE TOOLBOXKNOWFOLK
ARE WORKG COABORATIVY WI
THR SCOL DISICTS TO
UNRSTAND WT THE ISSU
ARE.
YEAH, LOCONTL IS
DENITELY THE RHT APPROACH.
ANDHE OTHER MOR BACK TO
SCHO STO THIS EK IS THE
BIG TEACHER SHTAGEN THU.S.
NAONALLY.
FER TEACHE TN FORE T 00
INEWAMPSRE, IN YOUR STAT
YOU HA RENED ME UCATN
CREDTIALS TH YR.
TREND NATIALLYND WHAT ARE
YOU ING DIFFENT IN N
RESUS, SIR?HAVE DIERENT
>> NIONAY, WHETHER IT'
ACHERSNUES.
THERE'S COUPROFEIONS
THAT HAVBURN OUT.
WENDERSTANTHAT NIONAY.
OV WHAT'S PPEN OVER
PASTOUPLYEAR
NEW HAMPSHI, WEE
FFERENT.
WEEALLY -- ON THAT LOC
WEORK LLABATIVELY.
EDUCATIOFOSTUDTS TEVERLIC
BEFO.
AND WEE CREANG ME ICE.
OPRTUNITIEFOR DS IPUBL
SCHOS TOET CREDENTLS IA
WO FORCEYPE ENVIROENT AT
EY WANT  EERNTO.
TRADITIOLLY.OING THING
ASPECT, U LET TEACHERSAV
SO SAYORKING WITH OSE
PARES.
CAL NTROL ISEALLY TH
ANY TIMEHE GOVERNMENT TS
SO WE TAKE TT PUACK TI, IT
WE BIEVE IN RENTS AND
TEACHERS.
WE'RTHE ONLYTATE IN W
POPULATI.T GROWINGN
BUSINEES A FLOODING .
WE'VREAL FOCUSN TH
INDIVIALS,NDIVIDUAL TOWNS,
INDIVIAL SOOLS.
AT ALLI THK KI OF
RING TIDFLOA AOATS
RE IN W HAMPIRE.
WEAVTHE RONGT ECONOMIN
COUNTRY.
INHE FST QUAER OF 2022 WE
WE THENLY STATE WITH THE
POSIVE G.
ERYTNG IMOVI FORN A
POSIVE DECTI.
THIN PITIC ASPTS OF E
PARENTS TTERGHT.
TEHERS MATTER.
WEE BE ABLE OSTER THAT
HERE.
WE'RE OUD  THEACT AT
WE'VE EN AE TO INCREASE THE
COUPEARSTEACHE OVER E ST
>> WT DO YOU MAKE FLODA
FIRST RESPONDERSITHO SAL
ACHI DEGREES TO HE FIL
>> LOOK, I LE THE EA OF
FOSINGN LITA, CUSING
ONETERS, FUSING ONOLKS
WI REAL WOD EXPERIENCE.
YOU GET THEM INTO OSE
GO THROU T CREDENTL LYA
LYNG.
STREINING THREGUTORY AND
CERTICATION OCESS,HETH
IT TEAERS OR MUFACTURERS,
THAT'SN OPRTUNEVERY
STATHAS.
WEE DOING IT HE.
WE'RE STAMINING OUR OLE
THING.
CIPRITY WE HAVE WITH PCES
LIKEAINE, RMONAKIT
EA FOR FKS TO COME OVER THE
I LOHE CONPT.
SHORTAGEHAS WO FORCE
LET'S STOPLLOWING GOVERNNT
GEIN T WAY OGETTG ESE
PEOPLE OTHFLOORS, IN T
TO DO TO GIVE EM AOB.E
D GET KI OR GET E PRUCT
OUT.
AT'S WHAT IT'S A AUT.
MAIE HASSEN IS UP FOR IC
ELECTIONTHE GOP IMARY
EKS AY.
POLLHAS RETIRED.
N BALDIC LEADING.
THEORIST THAT REATS UR
PARTS CHANCEATINNI BAC
THSEAT.
ARE YOCOERNE
IS THERE AORRYN YO PTY
ATOPOULDE MISSG OUT ON
A GOEN OORTUTY?
IN NEMBE HASN'GONNA SE
SHE SPEN$25 MIION.
MOVED.AL RING SN'T
OFHE DOCRATS MEYILLION
WEAVSEEN RES.
HAVSEEN NIONAL
SCUSON.
WHENOU ECTHE WRONG
INDIDUALIT MES IT MU
HARDERO WIN IN NOVEMR.
U HAVE TO HAVE GOOD NDIDE,
QUITY NDIDATESTHE END OF
E DA WHEER Y'RE RUNNG
FOR A PLNING BOARD, S.
SETE OPRESIDEN
YOHAVE GOTO T QUALITY
CAIDATES THAT CACROSTHE
LINE.
NOTHING.RIMARY MEANS
YOU N'T VERNF U DON'
WIINOVEMBER.
THAT'SLL TMATTERS.
I FOS  WNERS.
CAN WIN.BEST CANDIDATES TH
I NTHE BT NDIDATESHAT
HAVE T BEST SHOT AT BEING
GGIEASSEN.
AT'S WHY'M FOCING ON OER
CANDATES.
I N'T WANTHAPPEN TNEW
HAMPIRE AT WE'VE SHAPP
THER STES WHERTHAT GAP
BECOMETOO G.
YOU' SING  I
I STILL INTHOSE PUBLAN
CANDIDES C WIN.
TIME OF  TTHEY SHOULD HAVERD
IN WHAT SHOU BE WIOU
NATIONAL, THPROBLEM IS TS.
WE AREALKING ABOHINGS THAT
AREN MATTERI, TH DON
MAER TO THE VORS.
THE VOTE CARABOUT KITCHEN
THEY CARABOUT INFLION.
EY CE ABOUT VING OPTNS
FOTHEIR KIN SCHOOLS.
JAARY 6TH, WHAT PPENHERE
VERIMPOANT.
THPOS.'T DRING FOL TO
THE TING BTH.IVIOLKS IN
HAVE TO GETACTO OUR
IF WE DOHAT,EPUBLICA
ACRO THE BOARDAN BE VE
SUCCSFUL
>>OU TK ABOUT POTICS HERE.
VISITED NEW HASHIRE TH WEEK.
SO D REPLICAN STPHAEURTOM
COTT.
A HU ROSR OTENTIAL024
CANDATES HAVE VITED UR
STATE IN RECT MONT
'S AREAT STE.
STUDIO WTINGO TA TMEE E
HALEY, TIMCOTT.TIE, NIKKI
ITEALL THE LGOES ON.
A T OWDEIN THETATE. GEING
TRYI TO GET U TO HELEM.
WHAT DO YOU KE OF THIS?
WHY TH'RCOMING TNEW BOUT
>> O YEA
NO, I LK TO ALTHE NDIDATES
WHO NT TO COI'LL HPILY
SIDOWN WITALL  THEM.
IFE DOT CLOSTHE DEALN
2022,. AIN GONNAATTE
WE HE TOTARTOCUSG ON
KING SURE WE CRO T FINH
WIING CK THEENATE.
I THK WE'RGOING TOET THE
HOUS
THE SENATE, W HAMPSHE SHLD
THAT ST VE NOW.
I INK ITOING TO
WE REALLGOT TOAKSURE WE
CLOSTHE DEAL.
CAMPAIGN HERE  A LITE
FFERT.
U GOTO LOOK OPLE IN THE
EY
THE RUING KE IN NEW
HASHIRE IS, HEY, YOU GON
VO FORRESIDENTRUMP?
I N'KNOW
I VE ONLY MET HIICE.
YOU HAVEO BE ABLE  INTEGRATE
WITH FOL ITHEIR LIROOM
D THEIBUSINEES.
IF Y DO AT, YOU N BE
I'M KINDF LIKEHEEFEREE.
>> THE REFEE WHO SAULSERY
POPUR INOUR ATE.
LOS LIKE YRACE IGOING
RY WELL.
HA YOU TALD TH ANYONOR
>> YOUEAN INERMS OF WH?
O TH'RE GOING TO BE
SUPPTING?
DONO COMUP ALL THEIME D
CANDIDATOR TT CAIDATE?
>> MAYBEOU'RE RUNNG R
SOMEING SE, GOVEOR?
E YOCONCNED,OUAVAL
ESE OPLE COMING IN.
THEYE ALSAID T SAME ING,
IF CHRINUNU RU FOR
PRESIDT, TCHANGES THE
>>T IS TRUC, RIGHT
.
>> NO.
PEOPLE A TKING.
THAT IS  MESSAGEEVERNE
INHIS COUNTRY.
STOP WRYINABOUT '24.
OCK  DOO, CKP TH
THATAS TO BE DON
THE'LL HE PLEN OF TI
THPOLICAL NDSCE TODAY
WI BE TOTAY DIERENT JUST
E YEAR FM NOW.
EVENHAT LL BE SIX MONTHS
FROM T FIR PMARYN W
HAMPSHE.
>> YOUENTI JANUARY 6
YOU MEION MAR A LA.
YOU HAVEAID YOU ARE NO
ANTIRUMP BUTANY SA YOU
WERE AHORNN THFORMER
FORMER VE PRIDENT MIKE PEN
TOUCHEON THE BACASH AF
WAH. HE .H M A LO.
>> OURARTYTANDS WI THEEN
D WOMEN O SERVONHEHIN
BL LINE  T FEDERAL AND
STATE AND CALEVEL.
THESE ATCKS HE F MT
ST.
CALLS TO DUNTHE FBI ARE JUST
WRO AS CALLTO DEFD THE
POCE.
>> WT DOOU ME OFHE
ARCHF MAR A LAGO, SIR, AND
OF TS FICE BACKLH?
>> SO, COUPLTHINGS
I INK BIGGT ISE
AT WE'VE A BEEN LKING
THE FACTHAT EN YOU A GNG
HOUSE THAT CLELY BIDEN A
GAAND,HEY HAD  SATEG
WEE GOING  TAKE SANG
PRECEDEND TION, SO WE
THFACTHAT  ARE WEEKSN
NOW.
THEY ARE NOT SHOWING AARDS.
E LACK OTRANSPARCY IS
INRIATING.
AT'S WHE THEHAVE
ABSOTELY BLO IT.
THAT WHEHEY'VE LT E
UST OF T AMECAN OPLE
BEUSE  JUST OKS POLITIL.
I GETHIS WHO THI, WE,
U N'T WANT TSCLO
THINGSF IT'SACTI
INVESTATIO
BEFO.OD HAVE BN THGHT OF
THEY DIDN'T AICIPTHIS
AMERICANEOPL WELL, THERE
MONS.
THEYEALLY AR
YOCANN WALK INTO A FMER
GEBACKO YOU LATEAY, WE'L
NOT ACCEPTLEO THE AMERICAN
OPLE
SO THI MIKE NCE, BTHE
Y, GATUY, HAS DO --
PRESIDENOMAL JOB AVICE
HE RHT.
WE SHOULDN BE TALKING OU
DEFUING FBAND POCE
'RE REBLICS.
WEUPPORT LAW ENFCEMENTVERY
BUT IT WAS DASTER AN